THE GAME BECAUSE YOU CUT THE IC
SNAPS ITCK PAUL, GOING TO THE N
THROROOULD
HAVE COME AROUND ANDET LINEUP.
WHEN YOU GETOFF.
THIS IS INTO DAWS, AND THE DAWS
BIG REBOUNUN ABOUT AROUND,
SKIPPED FREE.
SUBBAN PUTS IT OFF THE CROSS BAD
POTS AND
HAS IT BACK, SHOOTS AGAIN,
MURRAY WITH A STOP ANDFIRST.
>> LAST TIME THESE TWO TEAMS
PLAYED, THERE WAS ONLY ONE
IT IS PAVEL ZACHA COMES DOWN
FROM THE BLUE LINE THAT
RETRIEVES THE PUCK AND].
>> NICK PAUL. ON THE ICE, THE
SE
GARY
>> AN IMPACT PLAYER.
OTTAWA IS  IT INTO THE
CORNER FOR HISCHIER.
HISCHIER THROWS IT IN
OF IT IN THIS GAME.
HISCHIER DOES A STOP AND GO.
CATCHES TWO SENATORS.
>> MARK KASTELIC WAS IN
HE INTERFERENCE WITH THE GOALIE.
BUT HIS SKATES ARE OUTSIDE THE
BLUE LIKE THAT TOUGH SPOT FOR T.
GOOD JOB BY TIERNEY WINNING THE
BATTLE AND GAUDETTE COMES IN AND
RIPS THIS NICK
HOLDEN FOR NOW.
SO WE'LL SEE IF IMPACT HE
HASHISCHIER THROUGH
THERE'S A LOOK AT SOME OLINE.
DROPS IT OFF.
CONNOR BROWN WITH A SHOT, DAWSS
ZONE.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH CHABOT, HE'S
LKED IN BY BROWN AS HE TRIEDSH .
BUT MATT MURRAY, AND THE POWER
PLAY GOAL AND THE DEFLECTION
EARLIER IN THE GAME BY HISCHIER,
AFTER THAT HE'S SHUTONE A GOOD
TONIGHT.
>> HERE'S SMITH, DOWN THE OTHER
NET.
AND HE SHOT,
IT IN FRONT.
PAUL IF FRONT, SHELF.
HE THROWS IT TO FORMENTON AND
THEN WHITE IS TAKING FORMENTON